[Music]
got three weeks ago i enrolled in the
academy after the
uh rent to rent and the brr
and i've
just i put an offering yesterday which
i'm almost accepted today on seven bed
day two more for 220 000 pounds we had
to pull 30 grand back out the jail plus
obviously randomly renting an alpha 40k
a year which is uh and it'll make us
about two grand a month profit on that
um well i personally have always i've
always been in construction and we're
moving in the development sector with a
business which i've got a third of the
shares in
um that's 26 bungalows that's that's a
six-figure deal a nine-month program
duration and like i said uh not all
that's all happening yeah but it's well
it's it's learning about the mechanisms
which which you can sort of supercharge
your properties with i mean i've always
been aware of the hmos and getting
multiple rents for the it's really
learning the finer details which which
is what you pay the money for you're not
domain it's uh like you say you you
learn enough people that are approving
products so
it's just a copy and paste job the way i
see it and if you do it for yourself you
know at the moment hopefully we get this
hm over the line the next couple of
weeks and me and the boys are going to
turn that around ourselves
and hopefully in the next couple of
months do it in phased and
systematically so leave some tenants in
to cover the bills
then add a move through the property and
refurb it from top down effectively
um and of that obviously but i've i've
gone in with it to me may to a tradesman
uh i'm project managing quantified by
trade quantify and short country numbers
on the deal which he have done and
obviously i'll bring them boys in so we
turn it around so
and then after that it'll be on the next
ones but i think i needed a bit of skin
in the game or me on it two more than i
can go and get the rent for enter
tomorrow's because then then you're
gonna like you say you're pretty you've
got something behind you then it close
to nothing so
i think that's important the first one's
always going to be the artist so if i
get one of these over the line then you
just crack on from there
it's a property that i saw it's for sale
right so i called up and i wanted to see
if i could probably get a lease option
it's basically a tired landlord and when
i went through the details the rental
income is like 40 grand a year
so it's like why would you want to get
rid of a property that's fully up until
june next year yeah for 40 grand a year
so basically clearly it's telling me
that this landlord is tired she's tired
so it's a six bed hmo
already left and that cause of the agent
oh nothing needs doing to it it's fully
lit until next year and i just want to
get rid of it basically
and i thought let me call them again and
see if there's any more so i called them
up again and i was just like actually i
just booked a viewing fee for you guys
on wednesday
do you guys have any more you
he's like actually yeah there's like
four of the same type of property in the
area and he doesn't want to sell them
individually just want to sell it off as
a portfolio but i was just like
yes
so that's five there
and then i pulled up this other agency
um
it's similar area and i'm just like can
i look up for this one yeah i looked at
the rental income it's like 28 grand a
year i'm like why
you getting rid of a five bed property
but you got you know when you're in
balance
and it's rented up until next year fully
booked contracted and everything
so um i called them back again is there
any move that you have and she's like
yeah actually this is the whole one
around the corner so um we can do one
and a half past one and we can do this
one at two o'clock
i was just like
thank you very much
yeah i'll take that thank you very much
i'm just i'm a dude
[Music]
what just happened
what the heck just happened yesterday i
had no luck i had the worst luck with
the hsn managers but today it's just
it's just i stayed up for one of the
last night sourcing deals or investors
that i met here oh wow and today it's
just like it's just 10 you know
all thumbs up for me i'm shocked
i'm really
uh yeah my name is james matt manus uh
basically i've just booked a viewing for
a building obviously in wakefield it's a
full bed uh multi-let
currently half occupied at the moment
but it was open for a corporate let so
i'm guessing they might be struggling
obviously with previous tenants and i've
just managed to book that into next
thursday so plans would be potentially
service accommodation
um
and yeah absolutely just starting out
it's my first one really so looking
forward to it
so what time is best for your monday
um sunday's the earliest i can come
one o'clock monday's fine if you just
follow me with the details the address
yeah your contact number contact number
it'll be perfect i'll see you at 1
o'clock on monday
yeah
awesome you just text me yeah
awesome that's perfect thank you very
much
i appreciate it take care bye-bye
yeah
okay so basically we found this guy
like so direct yeah so we did it so i
rang him
um basically said i've got a business
partner called james
he was very direct very kind of slow he
reckons he's an estate agent very blunt
he said if you've done your research can
we can you
give me this every month
so we did some figures but was super
conservative we went on a spare room had
another look we thought right we can at
least get 900 pound room for a double
room um
so it worked out that it'll be 18
1800 profit and then obviously take away
um any expenses bills things like that
but hopefully you'll be pulling a clean
profit of 12 to thirteen hundred because
it's relatively five percent yeah five
bedrooms
so it's all good let's go let's get more
more more
thank you so much have a good day bye
oh god
oh god
i just uh oh way out adrenaline is too
much
breathe
oh i might have to kill my first essay
but he's really hard because he was
asking me all these questions and trying
to get around because he's had really
bad experiences with another corporate
company late and i just look i
i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna lie and i'm not gonna say
i'm amazing you know but i can guarantee
you this this this this and i know that
i can do this this this for you and if
that works for you and you're happy with
it i'm more than happy to do it and send
you over my contract and he said yes
send it to me i'll have a look at the
contract and if we both parties are
happy then we'll go ahead with it well
i'm just shaking so much
mother it's really really good
you came across really professional and
very well so
i'm trying not to portrait that but
inside i'm like
are you good
i bought
three girls
which
[Music]
i'm
yesterday
[Music]
hmo um is landlord going to be there how
much you need to negotiate down at the
monthly rent to make it worthwhile
i'm gonna have a management company um
so
yeah so assuming you get it
what
and i have a management company
[Applause]
is
[Music]
you